So John Franklin was knighted for his first two journeys of exploration to the
Arctic.
Yet his third trip to the ice would prove to be one of the most disastrous
Seaborn expeditions of all time. He and his 128 men,
they simply vanished finale a decade.
A massive search was undertaken in the end though,
it was the perseverance of a wife who refused to let go that uncovered the
terrible fate in today's biographics. We discover the real story of,
so John Franklin and his voyage of terror.
So John Franklin born on April the 16th,
1786 in spills be Lincolnshire in England.
He was the ninth of 12 children to Wellingham Franklin and Hannah Weeks
Wellingham was a successful merchant,
which enabled him to provide a comfortable standard of living for his family.
John attended school at king Edward, the sixth grammar school.
He got his first view of the ocean at the age of 10.
And it was at this point that he set his mind on career at sea.
His father was not happy with the decision as he had a career in the church in
mind for John within two years.
However, William had softened. He allowed John to experience life at sea,
by going on a trial voy on a merchant ship.
This experience confirmed for John that this was the life for him.
He joined the Royal Navy at the age of 14. Within a few months,
he got his first taste of Naval war offer at the battle of Copenhagen.
At the tender age of 15,
Franklin served as a midshipman on the HMS investigator.
This ship was captained by Matthew Flinders with the mission to chart the
Australian coast Flinders was a cousin John,
and he took a personal interest in the training of the Yuca teenager.
Over the course of the two year expedition,
he was HandsOn in helping the boy get to grips with the fun doors of navigation
and surveying. After two years, the investigator became Mone worthy,
forcing the crew to transfer to the HMS poor boys for the journey home this
ship, it was wrecked on a reef 200 miles north of Australia.
Captain Flinders set off with several officers in an open boat on route to
Sydney in order to find help Franklin and the remainder of the crew were left
camp on the narrow reef refusing strips of sail for makeshift tens.
Six weeks later,
Flinders was back with a rescue ship upon his return from Australia.
Franklin secured a position as a signals officer on the HMS Eron.
He was on this ship during the battle of trau in 1805.
He didn't sustain any wounds during this battle,
but the roar of the cannon fire left him slightly deaf for the rest of his life.
Seven years later,
the very experienced 26 year old was involved in the battle of new Orleans
during the war of 1812.
He was at the head of a party that tried that failed to capture the city.
By the time of the end of the war against the United States,
Franklin had risen to the rank of left tenant,
but seeing that this was a time of peace.
There were now fewer opportunities for promotion for three years,
Franklin struggled to appointments. Then in 1819, for the age of 32,
he was given the mission of heading an expedition to the Arctic.
This was his first command.
The two ships that were to be used for the RT expedition were not Naval vessels.
Rather. They were whaling ships that had been purchased by the Navy.
The ship that Franklin was to lead the expedition from was called the Trent.
The other ship was the Dorothea with captain Barkin on board.
The mission was to head north in an attempt to reach the north pole and then
take a direct line to the baying straight in order to find a Northwest passage.
The mission was predicated on the open polar sea theory.
The theory was that the sea temperature increased between the Arctic circle and
the north pole by this reasoning,
once a ship had broken through the ice sheet north of Spitsbergen,
they would be able to make it through prior to the voyage meetings were held in
which scientists explained to Franklin.
And Bucken the rationale behind the theory, adding on this information.
Franklin said myself to making observation on the tides and currents the depth
of the sea terrestrial magnetism and atmospheric goings on during the voyage,
the ships, they set off from Shetland prior to departure,
the Trent was letting in water, the source of the leak. It couldn't be located.
This required meant constantly work. The pumps.
Franklin tried to recruit sailors from Shetlands,
but many of them refused stating that they would not go to sea on a leaking
ship. This is not exactly a good start.
It meant that Franklin set off shorthanded with a vessel that he could not have
full trust in.
The men had to man the pump and to work the wind last at the same time,
this person in AOUS amount of pressure on the crew,
and some of them even became overtaken by exhaustion.
It took several weeks until the leak was finally discovered and repaired in the
winter of 18,
19 Franklin set off on his first Overland expedition in the Northwest territory
of Canada, the party stopped off at Cumberland's house,
which was a fair trading depo on the Saskatchewan river,
the supplies that they were expecting to find though they were not there a
thousand miles further east at four trip away and they reached another.
But again, there were no supplies rather than turn back.
Franklin carried on though. He only had a single day's provisions.
He told the men that they would hunt and fish in order to feed themselves this
though, it was a Fullon hope and the men, they very nearly starved to death.
The expedition eventually made it to the Arctic coast. They were however,
only able to explore 500 miles before that lack of and harsh winter forced them
to turn back an Overland journey across the so-called Baron islands was an
unmitigated disaster.
The party of 20 men stumbled through uncharted territory in a state of near
starvation for days on ends.
All they had to eat was lichen 11 men died with the others being rescued by
copper Indians who helped them get to the safety of Fort enterprise.
Back in England, though, Franklin was given a hero's reception.
He was lauded for the courage that he had displayed during adversity becoming
known as the man who ate his boots for his resorting to chewing on his boot
leather while in a state of starvation.
After recovering from the ordeal of his first command,
Franklin met and fell in love with girl by the name of Eleena and portent in
1825, they had a daughter Eleanor Isabella in February of 1825,
Franklin set out on another Overlands journey.
This time he planned to follow the course of the McKenzie river to the sea,
and then explore the coast a week after he left his wife,
Eleanor died of tuberculosis.
Franklin had no knowledge of the tragedy and faithfully wrote letters to his
wife until April. At which time he read about her death in a newspaper,
despite this personal tragedy,
Franklin's second voyage was far more successful than his first.
He returned to England in 1827 to much a claim.
The following year he remarried his second wife's name was Jane Griffin,
who had been a friend of his first wife.
Franklin was Knight in 80 29 to recognize his Arctic exploration work.
During these years on land, he put on a substantial amount of waste,
perhaps in compensation for his years of starvation on the ice from 1830 to
1833, he commanded the HMS rainbow.
As it patrolled the Mediterranean during the Greek war of independence.
Then in 1836, he was made lefthand governor of van demons in Australia. Today.
This is known as Tasmania.
Franklin enthusiastically threw himself into the task of reforming the islands,
but he was stifled by colonial infighting. His colonial secretary,
John Monague seemed to undermine every move that he made.
Eventually he sated the man and Monague complained that the British prime
minister who agreed that the dismissal had been unlawful,
the decision was made recall Franklin. However,
the situation was handled badly with the replacement lefthand governor arriving
in Tasmania four days before Franklin had even been informed of his dismissal,
a deeply frustrated Franklin arrived back in London in June of 1844.
The timing was fortuitous as the British Admiralty was planning another Arctic
expedition from the moment he heard about it, Franklin was desperate to lead.
He felt that he was extremely qualified for the job on the basis of his two
previous expeditions.
The Admiralty agreed and Franklin was officially appointed to commands.
The two ships that were to undertake this mission.
They were called the Arabs and the terror on the strength of Franklin's previous
Arctic expeditions only about 500 kilometers of Arctic coastline remained
unexplored. This latest voyage was designed to complete the task.
The command of the Arabs was given to captain James Fitz.
James command of the terror was given to captain Francis Crosier who had
commanded that ship on a previous voyage, the Antarctic between 1841 and 1844,
the 59 year old Franklin who was given overall command.
Both ships had been recently outfitted with new technology.
These innovations included steam engines,
a library boasting more than a thousand books and three years worth of preserved
and tint food supplies.
The expedition set sail from green height in England on may the 19 13 45 in
total, there were 24 officers and 110 men.
They headed north picking up supplies on the Orne islands.
They then set course for Greenlands.
They were escorted by the HMS blur and a transport ship named the Barreto
junior.
Next up was disco islands in Bathon bay off the west coast of Greenlands here.
Five men were sent home on the support ships due to wellness.
This brought the final crew number down to 129.
The two ships and the men on board were last seen by Europeans on the 26th of
July, 1845. On that day,
the whale prince of Wales came across few ships alongside an iceberg.
And Lancaster sounds between Devon and the Baffin islands.
What happens after that is a matter of speculation.
It is thought that the winds of 1845 to 1846 was spent on beachy islands in
none of Canada, the two ships became stuck in the ice,
just off king William island, sometime in September, 1846.
And they never got free.
By early 1847 Franklin's wife was growing increasingly concerned at the fate of
our husband. Two summers had come and gone,
which was the length of time that Franklin had told her that he would be away.
A Naval officer offered to lead an expedition to search for the two ships,
but the Admiralty replied that they had unlimited confidence in the skills and
resources of sir John Franklin, as a concession. However,
the Admiralty did offer a reward to any whalers who could report any information
about the progress of the expedition through Lancaster sound. Meanwhile,
an old friend of Franklin's by the name of John Richardson made his own plans to
Mount a search party.
He knew that the expedition's food resources would run out in the summer of
1848.
He planned an Overland journey to the sea between the copper mine and McKenzie
rivers.
This was in the case that Franklin had made his way down the north American
coast teaming up with group of men from the Hudson bay company Richardson headed
down the McKenzie river to the coronation Gulf in the summer of 1848,
but they found nothing back in England.
The Admiralty was starting to get worried with no news of the Arabs and the
terror by the autumn of 1847.
They prepared to send out their own search parties in January of 18 48,
2 ships set out the HMS Clover and captain Moores,
the HMD Herald and captain KET.
They headed for the bear airing straight to explore whether or not the two ships
had become stark near the Western exit of the straight two more ships.
The enterprise under captain John Ross's headship and the HMS investigator under
captain Burr headed out in June of 1848 to go into Lancaster sound from the east
in an attempt to follow Franklin's tracks. These moves though,
they were not enough for Jane Franklin.
She wrote letter us to the us presidents and the Russians saw asking them to
help in the search operation.
She also set a larger reward for the whalers than the Admiralty hat.
She actually even made plans to buy her own ship and to commission her own
expedition hope was raised when the captain of a whaling ship reported that the
Indian INDs had spoken of four ships that were frozen in the ice in a channel
south of Lancaster out.
But when the investigation and the enterprise returns having seen nothing in
that area, the claim was dismissed.
Further searches were sent out by the Admiralty in 1850,
the HMS investigator and HMS enterprise set out again,
this time to search both ends of the Northwest passage.
They joined the Clover and the heralds, which were still searching.
Four Naval ships were sent to Lancaster sounds.
The ships had balloons on board that were let looser for the ice with notes
attached to them, telling the missing men, if they were still alive,
that help us on its way.
By this time the crew would've spent five winters on the ice.
So the belief that any of them were still alive was pretty optimistic to say the
least private expeditions. They were also sent out to join in the search.
A number of ships came together of the entrance of Wellington channel between
corn wall and Devin islands. Finally,
at a distance of about 230 miles from the entrance to Lancaster sound from
Baffin bay, they found something that's Cape Riley on beachy islands,
the remains of the 1845 to 1846 winter camp was found along with the graves of
three men, two American ships advance and rescue joined in the search in 1850.
They both got trapped in the ice and drifted for more than a thousand miles out
of Lancasters sounds before finally breaking free in 1851,
lady Franklin was greatly boyed when she received news that the winter camp had
been found,
but she was crushed when the search party was aborted due to an early autumn
freeze.
She now directly contacted a Hudson officer named William Kennedy who agreed to
Mount a search with left tenant, Joseph Rene, below of the French Navy.
As second in command. This expedition is set out in the summer of 1851,
but found no traces of either the ships or any more camps.
Various searches continued through the spring and summer of 18,
as well as sending up message balloons,
Arctic foxes were caught and then released with rescue messages attached to
their colors. It was all to no avail though.
And every ship returned without success.
It was thanks largely to the constant lobbying of lady Jane FRA an that the
Admiralty continued to Mount the search. After six years,
lady Jane also stirred up public sympathy for the plight of her husband and his
crew.
The Admiralty agreed to send out a final search expedition in the spring of
1852.
It was to be commanded by captain Belcher and consist of the resolute and the
assistance along with the steamers Intrepid and pioneer assistance and pioneer
had did north up Wellington channel while the resolute Intrepid headed west a se
blow ship. The north star waited a beachy island. Meanwhile,
the HMS investigator, which had set out in 1850 had not returned.
Then in April of 1853,
an Overlands party from the HMS resolute crossed Melville sounds and came across
the investigator, trapped in the ice in mercy bay, on the north of banks island,
the men on board, they were starving to death.
The rescue arrived just as the captain was about to send out a desperate party
on a 1000 mile track to a Hudson's bay post on the McKenzie river
in such a food. Finally in 1854,
a Scottish Explorer by the name of John Ray discovered the fate of Franklin and
his man Ray was surveying the booth peninsula on behalf of Hudson's bay company.
It was there that he was given the story of the explorers by Inuit hunters.
The story was that the ships had become stuck in the ice.
The men on board couldn't get free. And so headed out on foot to find a way out.
Then they had fallen victim to either starvation or to the cold Inuits told Ray
that some of the men had even into cannibalism. Then in 1855,
another Hudsons bay man by the name of James Anderson came across one of the
boats from the terror at the mouth of the great fish river.
Some Inuits then showed him items that could have only come from the terror and
the Arabs in January, 1854.
The Admiralty declared that the members of the expedition were assumed to be
dead.
Their wages would be paid to their relatives up until month March the 31st of
that year, lady Franklin would not accept this finding, but after so long,
she was now out on a limb. The London times editor wrote that to continue.
The search would be wasting time upon a search for dead men's bones.
It was now up to Jane Franklin to find the truth about her husband's fate.
She bought a Scher rig steamy yacht called the Fox and put command of it.
An experienced Dr. Officer named Leo P McLin talk with 25 men. McClin talk,
set out to cross back in bay in the summer of 1857. However,
the ship spent the winter drifting into the ice in early 1858.
The Fox entered Lancaster sound and its way toward prince Regent,
inlets past fury beach to appoint near BEO Strait during sludging
operations in early 1859,
Linor came across a group of Innu who had items that must have belonged to the
missing men, including snow knives. Then in a village,
not far from Mattie island,
he purchased silver spoons and forks that were engraved with Franklin's initial.
Then you had sold him of a rack that was just four days journey away McLin and
his men. They headed to the south of the islands.
They found the body of a man dressed in a steward's uniform.
Then a 28 foot boat was found mounted on a sledge.
The boat was laid in down with clothing and other gear,
including 20 kilograms of chocolate. There were also two skeletons on board
At the Northern tip of king William islands. The searches found a campsite,
which they named camp Felix halfway between the boat and the camp.
Two piles of stones were found one to the north and the other to the south of a
bay here were found single page records of what had happened to the crew.
The notes were written by James Fitz, James in may of 1847.
One of them reads follows April the 25th,
1848 ships terror and Arabs were deserted on the
22nd of April five leagues north Northwest of this having been beset since
12th, September, 1846,
the officers and crews consisting of 105 souls under the command Aton F
RM Crosier landed here in latitude 69, 37 42,
north longitude, 98, 41 west.
This paper was found by L tenant Irving under the can supposed to have been
built by sir James Ross in 18 31,
4 miles to the Northwood where it had been deposited by the late commander gore
in June, 1847, such James Ross's pillar has not however been found.
And the paper has been transferred to this position, which is that in which, uh,
Jay Ross's pillar was erected. So John Franklin died on the 11th of June,
1847 and the total loss by deaths in the expedition has been to this date,
nine offices and 15 men.
The Fox sailed back to England having at least discovered the eight of the
husband of their patron.
When the items they brought back from the condemned crew were displayed in white
hole. It aroused a great deal of interest. Leo bald McLin talk,
received delighted for his efforts in the search for Franklin and his men. Yes,
it would take more than a century and a half before the two ships were finally
found in 2008, the Arabs was found eight years later,
the terror was rediscovered to the Southwest of king William island.
The ship was in pristine condition. So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do give us a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe. We've got brand new videos,
just like this several times a week. So subscribe,
if you wanna find out about those and as always thank you for watching.
Okay.